now is it me or has politics if not a
world gone completely nuts Governor Ron
DeSantis from Florida's declared war on
Donald Trump Boris Johnson is
threatening to sue the British
government the tyrannical Maniac Putin
continues to terrorize Ukraine well Noam
Chomsky or the father of modern
Linguistics as many call him is in my
view one of the great minds of Our
Generation he's a linguist a philosopher
a fiercely outspoken political activist
authored over 150 books looking at the
crumbling fabric of society and I'm glad
to say that Noam Chomsky joins me now
from his home in Massachusetts Mr
Johnson what a pleasure to have you on
the program
pleased to be with you I wanted to start
by asking you there's a famous Doomsday
Clock based on what a lot of experts
perceive to be the moment the world
basically ends that clock is now heading
towards the dreaded midnight uh at a
fast rate we're nearer to Doomsday
according to experts than we've ever
been
do you think I mean you're 94 years old
you've had an extraordinary life you've
seen lots of things not least world wars
um what do you think about the state of
the world right now and are we right to
be perhaps concerned that doomsday is
on its way
well the Doomsday Clock Was
set in 1947
shortly after the
bombings of Hiroshima Nagasaki at that
point it was Seven Minutes to Midnight
a couple years later in
1952 moved to Two Minutes to Midnight
when
United States and Russia
excluded thermonuclear weapons showing
that human intelligence had
Advanced if that's the right word to the
point where it could destroy everything
oscillated sense in the Trump years it
moved back to two minutes
later the analysts abandoned minutes
altogether moved to seconds to now said
at 90 seconds to midnight
for good reasons said in January I
presume it'll move still forward towards
midnight
we're now facing
questions that have never Arisen in
human history they will have to be
answered soon or else were essentially
finished
one of course is the threat of nuclear
war which is growing both in Europe and
in Asia the other is the inexorable
March stewards climate destruction we
have a couple of decades in which to
deal with it
methods are pretty well known if we
don't pursue them we will pass
irreversible tipping points and there
will be a steady decline to
undescribable catastrophe that's where
we stand now
I mean I would add a third of that
potentially purely based on what
Professor Stephen Hawking told me and
what turned out to be his last
television interview which when I asked
him what was the biggest threat to
mankind he said when artificial
intelligence learns to self-design then
that's it there are some experts out
there in the world of AI who believe we
may be approaching that eventuality
what's your view of of AI and that
threat
I think that's mostly science fiction I
mean in principle it is possible to
reach what's called Singularity to reach
a point where AI might move on
independently but this is such a remote
contingency that I really don't see any
it doesn't seem to be worth considering
very seriously especially when we think
of the imminent catastrophes that are
quite real
on the on the catastrophes that you
outlined taking the first one of nuclear
war
how close do you think we're getting to
that potentially happening with this war
in Ukraine in other words if Ukraine
with its offensive was to push Vladimir
Putin back if it looked like back home
in Russia he may be losing the war or is
even driven out altogether
do you think he's potentially the kind
of person who might actually use a
nuclear weapon to seize back initiative
well that's
it's conceivable uh tactical nuclear
weapons have apparently been placed in
Belarus uh the West is taking a
ghastly Gamble they're assuming that if
Russia faces defeats which
does not look too imminent but if they
do that Vladimir Putin will
package bags and slink away silently to
Oblivion or worse
and will not use the weapons that
everyone knows he has to escalate the
war up to the point of attacking NATO
supply lines in Western Ukraine in which
case there's growing confrontation with
NATO that once you step on the
escalation ladder it's very hard to stop
so it's possible there's also a serious
possibility of nuclear war in Asia in
fact U.S top military officials generals
have predicted that within a couple of
years we'll be in a war with China
should be understood that a war between
nuclear Powers is inconceivable
it means termination
if a country major nuclear power carries
out a first strike it itself is likely
to be destroyed even if there's no
retaliation If Only from the effects of
nuclear winter
these are not conceivable possibilities
but top strategists are talking about
them and planning for them in fact U.S
official policy strategic policy since
has been to be prepared to fight two
nuclear Wars with China two Wars but of
course they become nuclear Wars with
China and Russia this is beyond insanity
but what do you do if you have a
dictator like Vladimir Putin who thinks
it's completely acceptable to illegally
invade a sovereign Democratic country in
an effort to restore the Soviet Union to
its tsar-like Glory Days as he would put
it or if you're president G and you've
made it pretty clear you want Taiwan
back where it belongs as you see it and
you decide to do the same with Taiwan
what does the rest of the world do I
mean do we not have a moral duty to
stand up to that kind of thing the first
thing we do is try to be clear about the
facts of Vladimir Putin said that it was
the disaster for the Soviet Union to be
destroyed but he added anyone who thinks
it can be restored is out of his mind
that part of the quotation is not given
in the West
with regard to Asia
there has been for 50 years a
an agreement between the United States
and China it's called The One China
policy it was established in the 1970s
firmly explicitly unambiguously
said that China that Taiwan is part of
China but neither side will undertake
provocative actions to change this
situation it's called strategic
ambiguity it's held the peace for 50
years which is not inconsiderable in
international Affairs China is still
maintaining that position the United
States is abandoning it the United
States is now accusing China of calling
for a one China policy which in fact is
true they do and that's the official
policy of the United States for the past
50 years now being abandoned with quite
provocative actions and plans for
further escalation I can read you the if
you look at the official doctor and it's
not secret the United States official
Doctrine is to encircle China with a
ring of Sentinel States
U.S allies
South Korea Japan Australia Guam arm
them with Advanced Precision weapons
aimed at China
provided of course by the United States
you know it says you know escalating
that by sending
B-52s that's nuclear capable B-52s with
cruise missiles to permanent stationing
for the first time in Guam U.S military
Outpost Northern Australia uh flying
time to China meanwhile the U.S is quite
openly publicly calling for a commercial
War to prevent China from develop
developing official statement is we have
to prevent China's Innovation and
development I mean other provocative
acts are being taken
Advanced increasing diplomatic relations
contrary to the agreement in the one
China policy in the 1970s as I mentioned
but let me ask you let me ask you I mean
if China
notwithstanding everything you've just
said if China did invade Taiwan what
would be the morally correct response of
the West and in particular America
the morally correct stance is to prevent
it from happening there is no indication
that China is planning to invade Taiwan
if the United States increases the
escalation they might do it
in that case
the bars are down you can't see if you
move on to war with China we're
basically all finished but there's
really no point considering a remote
contingency when there are actual events
taking place like the U.S escalation of
the confrontation with China China is
not saintly by any means nothing like it
but if you look at the facts it's U.S
escalation the US has now enlisted
trying to enlist Europe in its
confrontation with China by expanding
native U.S has expanded NATO to the
indo-pacific region turning it into an
international
military system under U.S control
all of this is going on we can if we
like talk about the possible contingency
of a Taiwan of China invading Taiwan for
which there is no indication that it
could happen if we continue the
provocation remember the provocation is
serious it's both in the military
Dimension and in the commercial
Dimension quite openly what I've been
referring to is public policy very open
and it is increasing the threat you put
nuclear capable
B-52s in flying distance to China with
nuclear-tipped cruise missiles that's
provocation well I mean they would argue
of course that it's defensive that
they're actually these are protective
measures they're not provocative
measures they would argue that China's
march to economic imperialism and their
massive expansion of their military
represents an existential threat if they
misuse those Powers that's what they
would argue and therefore what they're
doing is protecting
and other countries from from nefarious
Behavior by China
it would suggest distinguishing between
Western propaganda and the facts so
let's take China's military buildup
this is reported regularly by cypri
Swedish priest Research Institute you
can pick it up on the internet you will
find that China's military
expenditures for the past 10 years per
capita military expenditures or a flat
straight line they have not increased
of course the China has increased its
military as the population increases but
it's way below U.S military expenditure
and the US's far above in technological
advances so yes and that China remembers
is faced with security problems at every
border the United States is faced with
no security problems but U.S military
expenditures dwarf
they're about the same as the next 10
countries all together it's a per capita
far beyond China so yes there is and
what when we talk about this uh economic
imperialism exactly what are we
referring to we're referring to
investment and development programs
throughout Eurasia expanding to Africa
expanding even the Latin America
the U.S is trying to stop them has found
no way to do it except by escalating in
the military and economic Dimensions by
trying openly publicly to try to prevent
China's economics development if you
don't mind me uh the risk of sounding
impertinent but you sound very trusting
of China and its motivations
no not the least I said explicitly China
is by no means and saintly plenty of
criticisms you can make of China but I
would like to describe the world
situation as it is not as it's presented
by U.S British propaganda okay let's
move to another issue I think we have
more common ground on Free Speech it
seems to me has never been under more
ferocious attack in the west than it is
right now why is that and what do we do
about it there definitely is an attack
on freedom of speech even freedom to
read in the United States
Ronda Sanders running for president as
he just announced has
imposed regulations laws in Florida
which make it illegal to teach
authentic American history you have to
teach a kind of History which glorifies
the United States nothing about what
actually happened this is happening in
Republican legislatures around the
country that the libraries are being
forced to throw out books there's
laws passed to say their topics are not
allowed to talk about well he would
argue I mean to scientists with argue
I've interviewed him he would argue that
he is focused on things like critical
race Theory which he feels is
inappropriate for teaching young
children he thinks that gender ideology
should not be taught to young children
and it has a lot of support a lot of
Floridians agree with him about this
critical race Theory what is critical
race Theory does anybody know
critical race theory is a slogan
invented by the right wing and the
person who invented it Christopher Ruffo
has been very open and Frank he says we
just use this as a way to refer to
everything we hate
if you want to know what critical race
Theory actually is it's a small academic
discipline which suggests which
investigates systematic elements of
racism racism in American Education they
certainly exist it's never reach the
schools schools wouldn't even know what
it is this is invented by the right wing
exactly as rufo stated to refer to
everything we want we hate and want to
destroy like teaching American history
like
teaching gender issues we hate that so
we'll call it critical race Theory but
it's a small academic discipline which
no one ever heard of until it was picked
up
primarily by rufu then expanded through
the Republican Echo chamber to be some
major attack well listen listen I don't
I don't disagree that the right
obviously have a lot of issues on the
far right in particular within a rise of
white supremacy in America a rise of
far-right uh domestic terrorism and so
on that's completely inarguable but also
we've seen a rise of what I would call a
very strange
uh version of liberalism this very Ultra
woke so-called liberalism which I would
liken more to Fascism albeit without the
extreme violence but the mindset of
wanting to control how people think
wanting to cancel people for having
different opinions de-platforming
speakers you don't like at University
and so on which to me is the antithesis
of what liberalism was supposed to be
what do you think of that phenomenon
I've been as you know probably very much
opposed to the
actions of small sectors of young people
who are picking up the traditional
cancellation which has been endemic in
the academic world and in the uh
political world for years I can give you
examples from my own experience
cancellation of the left has been
constant it's only very you want me to
spend time I could tell you from my own
experience which is smaller than now
small segments of young people are
picking up that same improper
policy and should be opposed we should
oppose it just as we should have opposed
the massive cancellation that has been
accepted for decades because it was
directed against the left and descended
opinion so yes it's wrong
let me ask you uh no I mean you're like
I said you're 94 years old is there any
great burning question in life that you
I find it hard to believe you haven't
found the answer to everything given how
massive your brain is but is there
anything left that you'll really you
would love to know the answer to that
you've never to your satisfaction worked
out
will moving to another domain of
intellectual professional Pursuits there
is a question that was asked by Galileo
then by his associates in the 17th
century which is as he had unanswered
how are you and I able to do what we are
now doing
hell as Galileo put it how is it
possible with a finite number of symbols
to produce an infinite number of
thoughts and even
use these symbols to allow others
who have no access to our minds to
access to their inner workings of our
minds how is this miracle possible was
raised by Galileo studied the measure
concern for Des Court
other leading figures in the 17th
century began working on it
we Now understand some aspects but the
major questions are
not only unanswered but we don't even
know how to approach an answer so that's
a leading one of many leading problems
and what is this what has been the when
you look back at your life what has been
the greatest moment of your life
I can't say a lot of Great Moments if I
had the power to let you relive One
Moment in your life what would you go
for
some moments
are almost miraculous
like the birth of my first child say
many other things like it but I don't
see much Point talking about my personal
life and situation they're more
important things in the world
do you feel the world is a is a better
place than when you were born or a worse
place
well I was born in 1928
right before the Great Depression which
of course was
far more severe than anything we've
suffered recently
uh fashion as I was growing up as a
young child
fascism was spreading through Europe
looked Unstoppable
actually the first article I remember
writing for a school newspaper began
with the fall of Austria Czechoslovakia
Barcelona was right after the fall of
Barcelona with Franco when it seemed as
if the fascist plague was Unstoppable
those were very dark moments it
another extremely dark moment was August
6 1945
when
I was then 16 years old old enough to
understand it was clear that humans had
were moving towards the capacity to
destroy everything that came a few years
later
uh has the world changed for the better
in many ways
take the United States country I know
best
go back to the 1960s
in 1960s the United States had
anti-miscegenation laws that were so
extreme that the Nazis refused to accept
them
in the united 1960s the United States
did have federally subsidized housing
but it was segregated not for blacks
that meant a black man couldn't maybe
get a job in a Auto Plant during the
boom period of the 50s but he couldn't
use it to acquire wealth wealth in the
United States mainly means property
enormous Legacy of hundreds of years of
slavery in Horrors women's rights were
not accepted in fact in the 1960s
in principle the United States still
accepted British common law which the
founding fathers had explicitly accepted
and according to that law of Blackstone
women were not persons they were
property the property of the father
handed over to the husband well that was
eroded over the years but it literally
wasn't until
1975 that the Supreme Court
formally determined that women or
persons their peers they have a right to
appear in federal trial well all of
these things have changed those are all
steps forward it's now called wokeness
but it's uh steps forward towards a more
caring egalitarian just Society
sometimes goes overboard but on the
whole it's been a very positive
development
when you again look at your life and its
totality what do you think your greatest
achievement has been
that's for other people to determine
you want to know what I think
it'll be something you never heard of
try me yeah
for 25 years I was spending a great deal
of effort in the United States in
Britain to try to stop the worst
atrocity of the post-war period the U.S
British spect Indonesian invasion of
East Timor which wiped out about a third
of the population that could have been
stopped instantly at any point it was
necessary to trade it engage large
masses of the population to compel
finally
1999 did compel Bill Clinton to call it
off
something was saved
it seemed impossible How could a small
island of a couple hundred thousand
people resist an invasion by a major
country supported by the greatest
military powers in the world
but
it finally succeeded
and your your support for that is in
your estimation your greatest
achievement
in the areas
of social and political policy one there
are others I was very active in from the
early 1960s when John F Kennedy
radically escalated the war in Vietnam
from that point I was devoted enormous
effort
to opposition to direct resistance faced
imprisonment
finally enough opposition to develop to
prevent Richard Nixon from moving on to
nuclear weapons as seemed likely so
that's an achievement
who who has been for you the best
American president of your lifetime and
who's been the worst
in my lifetime
FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt and the
worst
too much competition I'm afraid
I know you know you're not a massive fan
of Donald Trump how do you feel about
him running again
no
if he runs again it'll be a disaster for
the world
for many reasons
for one thing Trump as you saw during
his first time is dedicated
actually his he has two commitments one
commitment is to himself
he's a paranoia he's a
megalomaniac psychopath all that
concerns him is me the other commitment
is to serve corporate power and great
wealth abjectly is one legislative
achievement was a huge gift to tax gift
to the ultra wealth Ultra rich and the
corporate sector nothing else
but he is a major climate denialist he
denies that global warming is taking
place he wants to maximize the use of
fossil fuels including the most
dangerous of them
and to eliminate regulations which might
mitigate the catastrophe that's a death
sentence for the human species
domestically he's made it very clear
that he wants to Institute we would
properly call a protofascial state
eliminate the Civil Service
since the mid-19th century like every
other
Democratic Society the United States has
been a has had a non-artisan civil
service which does most of the
administration which keeps the Society
Running Britain has the same others have
the same but Trump has made it explicit
that he wants to eliminate it replace it
by loyalists who put in power that
undercuts
what remains a functioning democracy we
can go on it would be a colossal
disaster and it's not unlikely
you look at pose yeah no I mean he's
he's way ahead in the Republican
nomination polls what do you make of
over here in the UK breaks brexit which
is now eight years pretty much since we
voted to leave the European Union well
seven years
um and there's no sign of any of any
benefit from leaving the EU do you think
that was a a sensible decision by
Britain to do that I thought at the time
that it was a very serious error
uh both harmful to Britain
harmful to Europe
in a way beneficial to the United States
because
under brexit Britain becomes even more
subject to U.S domination than it was
before
but I thought it was a terrible mistake
and I think the record since
basically confirms that
do you think we should have a second
referendum most of the polls suggest if
we did it would be overwhelming support
now to go back into the European Union
buyers remorse yes I'm not surprised in
fact that was the case
almost immediately
you look back I mean you know better
than I do but if you look back at the
polls shortly after brexit they did
indicate a substantial con desire on the
part of the population to rescind it
that was a healthy position in my
opinion
who's been the the single greatest
public figure of your lifetime
in the world any anyone of any kind
they were Betty
one of them
this is a tragic example
is a very close personal friend for 50
years
no
facing terminal cancer
been moves to hospice
Dan Ellsberg
I think what he did was
magnificent
one of the great well I suppose how
would you describe him for those who
don't know his story
well
people should know his story Dan was
working at the top level of U.S
um
intelligent had one of the highest
class it was very much at the center of
strategic planning and uh analysis
he decided that there was a secret
history Robert McNamara
Secretary of Defense had commissioned a
secret history of the Vietnam War Dan at
the very top level knew about it
he and his friend Tony Russo both
working at the Iran Corporation at the
Hyatt you can't call it top secret it's
way above then didn't even have a
classification they decided that the
American population should know what had
been done in the worst crime since the
Second World War
shouldn't be kept secret so they copied
it released it tried to get the press to
cover it
finally the
actually then I was he did give me a
copy of it so I was able to write about
it as soon as it became public uh
bits and pieces of it were leaked in the
press the next Administration tried to
block it Supreme Court overruled them so
it did finally appear then he went on
for the rest of his life to try to bring
to the population
understanding and knowledge of the
high-level nuclear policies which are so
shocking
that it's almost impossible to talk
about them so nuclear policies going
back to the early 1960s
call for obliteration of China if there
is a confrontation in Berlin
nothing to do with China but you got to
use all the forces you have those are
the psyops the actual proposals Dan
tried very hard not with too much
success unfortunately to try to bring
the American population and the world to
understand the Hideous horrendous
threats of terminal nuclear war that are
right on the verge and if you look over
the history of the nuclear system it's
kind of a miracle that we've survived
and then case after case which came very
close very close much too close to
moving on to terminal destruction what
happened if you if you had
if we knew this was going to be our last
day on Earth I asked Professor Hawking
this actually I said how would you spend
it and he said he would get his family
together
he would play Wagner very loudly and he
would drink fine champagne
if you knew it was all about to end how
would you spend your last day
I would get my family together but skip
the rest
finally known chomsky's been an absolute
uh pleasure to talk to you so
fascinating to talk to you for hours
um what would you like your legacy to be
if you could write your own heading on
your own Tombstone here lies Noam
Chomsky he
or would you like the rest of that
sentence to say he tried his best
I think that's that's absolutely correct
and your best was extremely good and is
extremely good I'm choske thank you very
much indeed for joining me I appreciate
it thank you very much